many of you maybe most of you will never
to work another search problem by hand
in your natural life now this others
will want to take another run out of it
on the final i've been much criticized
for this way of doing grading in the
class but the way i look at it is that
the relationship between students and
instructors ought to be less adversarial
than it used to be in a good old days
when i was when I was a student I
especially remember a examination we
took all of us took on Raleigh
scattering that was 803 I think and back
in the old days we had to take four
physics courses not just two and we had
to take four math courses not just two
back in the days when well I was going
to say men were men but most of us were
men in those days I think we only had 20
women in our class anyway we had of
course we had a quiz on Raleigh's
scattering and I thought well this is
pretty hard and then I got my quiz back
26 I thought well I've been found out
I'm going to flunk out my father will
make me go to law school
I'll never attract anyone to marry
horrible things will happen then the
instructor announced class average was
18 I was two standard deviations above
that they gave us the same they gave us
the same exam two weeks later and
accounts vary some people say that the
class average went down anyway today
we're going to study some stuff we're
gonna study some stuff that will make it
possible if you understand how you can
do that computation in just a couple of
seconds even with the delays introduced
by the by the redrawing now this
particular program I'm not real sure and
I don't have a proof but I think it will
take more than the lifetime of the
universe to find a four car to find a
legitimate coloring of VO continental
United States but by the end of the next
class you'll see how to do that
lickety-split in just a couple of
seconds
with the redisplay delays now we could
of course do this in two ways one way is
I can start off by saying let's see be a
constraint satisfaction problem and just
give you the result and anybody can do
that that's great
and you need to learn some stuff that
way but there are some things that you
need to learn I think a different way
and that different way involves my
telling you the story of how it all came
to be this is a new field pretty much
and therefore I know most of the people
in it and I know all of the people who
did the work that I want to tell you
about today and I'm going to tell you a
little bit about the struggle for coming
up with the ideas that led to the lead
one of the most powerful one of those
powerful methods we learn about in the
subject it all has to do original E with
an attempt to make a computer capable of
seeing and everybody said to themselves
well let's start with seeing simple
things like children's blocks and so
Aldo faux Guzman a graduate student of
Marvin Minsky's was charged with the
summer project which led to his PhD
thesis of writing a program that could
look at a line drawing and determine how
many objects are in the line drive so
for example there behind my outline is a
line drive and you know instantly or you
believe instantly that there are two
objects there even though in some deep
sense it's ambiguous there are all sorts
of ways that you could through trickery
arrange something with even seven
objects that look that way but most most
people would say there are two objects
so Guzman said about the problem of
figuring out how to do that and then his
work was followed up by Dave Huffman and
his work was followed up by Dave Waltz
and his work was followed up by jean
freud or who's not listed there quite
yeah
and I want to tell you a little bit of
story how that all happened so Guzman
took a lot of pictures he went to Boston
baby the precursor to Toys R Us
purchased a large block set on a
government contract and to what about
the business of taking a lot of pictures
of them sort of get a feel for the
domain and eventually he decided that he
could build a program that could
determine that there are two objects
here by using the lines as s quanta of
evidence about which faces belong
together in an object so he said after
studying these for a long time that
these drawings tend to have a lot of
arrow type junctions and a lot of fork
type junctions and when you see an arrow
it's a little bit of evidence that the
objects on either side of the shaft are
the same the face on either side of the
shaft along the same object and over
here the fork type Junction it suggests
that the pairwise
three pairs of faces seem to belong to
the same object so with that idea he
could come back to a drawing like this
and start decorating it with these
so-called links these quanta of evidence
that phases belong to the same object
and if I've done it right you get
something that looks like so it's a
little hard to see what's going on on
the drawing itself so let me number
these
now I have the easier to deal with
picture there are two links between 1 &
2 & 1 & 3 1 lengths between 2 & 3 1
between 2 & 4 2 here 2 here and one each
from all of these so Guzman produces
this evidence for how the problem ought
to be solved and then it begins to think
about various ways of using the evidence
so he could and did decide that one
length is enough to presume that the
faces belong to the same object and you
can see that that's a little bit too
liberal because that says the whole
thing is just one object so Guzman the
rejected the one length the one link
theory and went to the Tulane theory and
the two link theory says oh well let's
see if we insist that 2 links so be
there before we are willing to decide
that it's the same object then these
three faces are pulled together into one
object these three are pulled together
into one object where the last 7 doesn't
share two links with anything so it's
left dangling out there so plainly the
two link theory is too conservative so
that as you would soon discover neni
UROP project would lead you to the third
theory which is two links repeated so
now that we form these super regions we
can come back and say will merge super
regions if they're connected together by
two or more links so nothing new happens
up here but this super region is joined
at 7 by more than by two or more links
so I pulls everything together like so
so that worked fine well it didn't work
fine there were lots of examples of
situations where it didn't work and
nonsensical such and in situations that
were considered nonsensical by us humans
because they just didn't didn't seem it
seems silly the kind of conclusions that
it reached so when the Guzman presented
this work in his PhD thesis defense it
said and who knows if it's true but it
said that Marvin Minsky thought it was
great work and we should make him a
professor
it happens that Dave Huffman was also on
the committee and said that it was ad
hoc and the thesis should be rejected so
we had two polar opposites of
impressions there Dave Huffman by the
way you've heard that name before I
imagine it's the it's the guy who
invented Huffman coding as a term paper
in a information theory course taught by
Bob Fano he got an a they say so Huffman
didn't like it he thought it was a
little bit too ad-hoc it was too
heuristic it didn't take advantage of
anything we might know about physics and
so people began to say well why does it
work and when does it not work and
that's just about the best question you
can answer in a situation like this and
by playing with some more of Guzman's
pictures and reflecting on them it
turned out that it worked because the
world is full of three-phase junctions
well let me say three things for Texas
because they're out there in the world
we'll reserve the word Junction for
something else and three-phase vertexes
generally project into either an arrow
or a fork so this one's whole program
worked on the weak backward conclusion
that if you see one of those it probably
came from one of these so this is in the
drawing that's in the world so by a
process is neither deduction nor
induction but rather abduction you see
one of those guys you say well they
often come from
preface vertexes in the world so if you
see one it probably came from the
three-phase vertex in the world that's
abduction
so what's the Huffman's all that being a
mathematician he began to think about
how one might develop a different and
better theory but we have to recognize
that all this work started off for the
efforts of Guzman who was an
experimentalist and huffman was a
mathematician so naturally they
approached the problem differently so
Huffman says I'm not going to concern
myself too much with the actual problem
that Gulen was trying to solve rather
I'm going to work in a very simple world
which I can deal with mathematically so
he decided that he was going to work in
a world which had several
characteristics characteristics number
one was that the world would be
presented in general position
that is a say no screw cases so if you
see a cube it's going to look like this
and it's not going to look like this so
that's out and this is in and the idea
here is that that's not general position
because you perturb your point of view a
little bit you'll change those T
junctions into Forks and arrows so we
don't had to deal with those kinds of
weird kinds of cases
so this that's presumption number one
presumption number two is that we're
going to be dealing with a world that's
trihedral that means all vertex is out
there are going to be formed from three
planes so we're going to have the
intersection of three planes so how many
kinds of junctions can you see if the
world is composed that way is the
question that Huffman sent himself upon
the next assumption was that they're
going to be four kinds of lines see
Guzman only recognized two kinds of
lines lines that have a length of lines
that don't have a length and they don't
have very much to do with the physical
world so Huffman says I want to get the
constraint out of the physical world so
I'm going to deal with four kinds of
lines concave convex and boundary all
right
so each of those kinds of lines is going
to be is going to have its own notation
we'll call the convex lines plus the
concave lines - and the boundary lines
are going to get an arrow on them
depending on which side of the object
you would which side you would see the
object if you walk along the direction
of this little arrow let me yeah sorry
thank you so concave convex and boundary
thank you
so this down here that's a concave line
and that would get a minus label oh I
don't know these lines you're seeing
here if there were stuff behind them
instead of me then all those would be
convex lines many times you see a
boundary line for example now you don't
see both sides of that line down here at
the bottom so that's a boundary line and
the arrow would point in that direction
so as to keep the stuff of the object on
the right as you walk along a kind of
mathematical convention so three kinds
of lines four kinds of labels and
there's some things left out that's
because Huffman wanted to keep his
problem simple something he can manage
by hand what's left out cracks or left
out shadows are left out there's nothing
to do there's presumption that there's
no nothing of interest here with respect
to that so let's have a little
vocabulary before I before I go on and
I'll try to stick to it but there's the
stuff out there that consists of
vertexes and edges and over here on the
blackboard will have junctions and lines
and I'll try to stick that vocabulary
all right
yes Christopher yeah there four kinds of
look what I weigh
questions didn't I say there are four
kinds of lines there are three kinds of
lines but since we can label a boundary
line in either direction we have four
labels okay it depends on which side of
the object this stuff is on and that
will be clear clear I think this as I do
an example so one two three assumptions
a little bit of vocabulary so we have
the possibility of making a complete
catalogue this is so simple we have the
possibility of making a complete
catalogue of all the ways that lines can
come together to form a junction with
respect to these four labels now at
first you might say oh my god that will
take a couple of years but maybe it will
take a couple of years and in the end -
perhaps you're surprised you discover
that there are only eighteen ways to
arrange the labels around a junction in
this world everything else is excluded
if you have something that's not in the
set we're going to produce now it can't
be built with trihedral vertexes so I've
listed up there six cells Five Forks for
T's and three arrows let's see if I can
figure out why there are those 18 and
nothing else well if we have three face
three vertex is coming together that
means there are eight octants right and
the stuff of the object may fill one two
three four five six seven or all eight
octants now of course if you fill all
eight octants there's no junction so we
don't consider that case if we don't
fill any of the octants there's no
junction so we there's no vertex so we
don't consider that case but it's just
one of the eight octants is filled with
stuff then we can look at it from any of
the seven remaining
Auctions so right now you're looking at
it from one of the seven remaining
opt-ins and if I'm not mistaken you're
going to see a fork-style junction there
right and you're going to see a
fork-style junction in which all of the
edges are con effects and unfortunately
an unfortunate selection of names
because the linguist tell me that we
index all of our words by the first
phoneme and those have the same first
phoneme so they're easily confused so
here's a fork style Junction and we know
that one way that's legitimate for the
lines that come in is with four pluses
now that's not the only way you can see
that and here's another way there's an
LTL Junction right and both of those are
boundary lines and we want to draw the
boundary line indicators on there so
that if we walk along the arrows the
stuff of the object would be on the
right so I suppose to make it easier for
me to do my drawing I should look at it
this way
and then I would say well that has to be
a legitimate way of labeling a junction
are there any more well there's there's
seven altogether but many of them are
the same there is one more that's a
little different though I can hold this
guy up like so and if I'm holding it the
right angle for you you see an arrow
style Junction right two boundaries and
the Barb is convex so in this particular
case I've got that I've got that and
I've got a plus there and that's all
that happen to be for the one octant
filled with stuff case I happen to be
able to reverse this though and here's
the seven octants filled case right so
that tells us that it's possible to have
a vertex outside under space that when
reduced to a junction on the board
deserves three minus labels because all
of these that you're seeing now are
concave so another fork-style junction
looks like so and since there's only one
octant to look at from
that completes our analysis of the of
the seven octants filled case now we
have a couple other possibilities here
we might have five options filled with
stuff so that means there are three
options that we can look from so let's
suppose that these little chalk pieces
are little people and they're looking at
this Junction down there where this
white object is fused with the table I'm
fusing it with the table because I want
to consider it to be one object we can
view it from the three objects indicated
by those three little chalk pieces and
ask ourselves well in the in the event
that we look at it from those three
places what do we see and if we look at
it from from the perspective of the
piece of purple chalk I'll have to walk
around to be sure looks like a narrow
junction with two concave and a convex
they get there right well so I'm looking
at it from this perspective it's an
arrow this is convex and these two are
concave because I fuse the paper the
paper box with the table looking at it
from the perspective of this blue guy
let me rotate it so you can have a
better understanding of the blue guy it
looks like a concave line and a boundary
so it's an L and this one is a boundary
and that's concave and by a kind of
symmetry we're also going to get that
one from the other side the third of the
three octaves well we're often running
but we still have an awful lot to go and
we could we could manage to deal with it
by thinking about this object once again
but instead of instead of this situation
out here to turn it around and look at
this vertex think about the junctions
that it can produce I think I'll do that
for you because you really have to play
with this and move it
a little bit to see how things are going
to look so let me let me think about how
that's going to work out I know that one
of the possibilities is going to look
like so I might as well not hide that
from you it's going to be what happens
when there's a little man looking up at
the junction and this one's going to be
- and now we got two more there just
like that it look like so and you say
oops
you say aren't those just the rotational
variants of each other and the answer is
sure I write them all down because if
you get a fork style junction in space
there are three different ways that can
be labeled depending on which of the
which of the lines you put the minus
minus label on so that takes care of
that and then there's a one more of
these fork style junctions and that's um
plus plus minus that derives from this
case and there appear to be three more
of these L style junctions and they look
like
let's see plus then plus I'm having to
think this through as I go and then and
that's it what about the t's well in
this world the only way you can get a T
is if some object is obscuring another
object and if an object is obscuring a
line it can be any line at all so that's
why the four remaining ones are easy
beyond description to label and of
course the cross pieces of the T are all
boundary lines with the obscuring object
on the right now let's see we've taken
care now of the one three five and seven
object octants filled cases what about
two four and six well it turns out you
can have vertexes that are made that way
too
but they will have more than three faces
have six faces you'll be like what
happens when an object comes together at
a point like so like that you can play
with a little bit and see that if you
have two four or six objects filled with
stuff there are more than three faces so
we're going to ignore those so our
constraint is going to be a little more
a little more severe than
would be suggested by the terminology
Huffman use is its they're going to be
try he'd roll all right they're also
going to be three phases so we went to a
lot of work there but what do we
discovered who discovered it in this
world this is a complete 100% nothing
excluded nothing else can be there
catalog of all possible ways that
junctions can have line labels arranged
around them there's nothing else in this
world so that's a very powerful
constraint so now let's see what we can
do with it this example is usually more
fun when the Red Sox are doing better
but they're not it yet we'll use it
anyway
we're going to start with a with an
object that looks like home plate and
now I ask you the question can you build
one of those I don't know let's give it
a shot we're going to assume that this
object is hanging floating in space so
therefore all of these lines around the
boundary are boundary lines like so now
that gets us off to a good saying in
space Christian all right you look
confused just hanging in space so
otherwise around the edges are places
where you see only one one only one side
has stuff on it so so that enables us to
just quickly run around the periphery
and put arrow labels on all those
outside lines now we have a lot of arrow
style junctions on the boundary that's
commonly the case so we can run over to
our catalog of all possible labels and
we see that if we have an arrow with
boundaries on its barbs there's only one
of those so I know instantly that there
must be a plus on the shaft so we can
come back here and take all these arrows
here and label them with plus lines on
their shafts and a line can't change its
nature along its length so if it's a
plus line on one end it's going to be a
plus line on the
learn all right so what else can we do
here is in the deep inside is a
fork-style junction
it's got concave markers I'm sorry
convex markers on both of those two
lines so we go over to our catalog and
say what can we say about it given that
there are pluses on two of its lines
what that means that the third one has
to be a plus as well and now we're done
we've labeled everything except for this
what about that guy there's an error
there's an L style Junction with pluses
on both of its two lines is there one of
those in my catalog No
therefore I haven't passed a necessary
condition for constructability in the
world that I've made you can't make it
you can't construct it so Huffman's
ideas give us a way of testing something
to see if it's not possible for it to be
in this world if it passes the test does
that mean it's possible no it's a
necessary but not sufficient condition
on this one look all our occupation on
this one maybe it will help if we put in
another line for example we could put in
a line like so you feel better about it
now I don't know me let's see this has
to be a plus for the same argument we
used on several other arrows before that
gives us a arrow style junction here
with a plus on everything is there such
a junction label no we lose doesn't help
you think you can make it but you can I
think
you should be constructive as a 3G he
thinks you can construct it as a 3d
object let me show you the next example
Christopher consider this example you
make that your intuition is yes so let's
label it
I've already lost we just boost that up
a little bit to make it the situation
more clear so already I've got myself in
the situation where I can't label that
but you feel like you can make it so
what's what's wrong what's wrong is what
Eliot putting a little interpretation on
what Eliot has said if you look at this
situation back here you get a four faced
Junction there so you can make it but
not with three faces so some of these
some of these look like you can make it
but they can't be labeled because you
need more than four faces at a junction
and we can carry that idea back here if
you can you can make this okay but this
Junction you got two in the back and two
here so it has four faces same idea all
right so that's that's that's that's
coos month's contribution that's
Huffman's contribution Huffman was a
mathematician but we wanted to build
robots back in those days neither one of
these guys solve the problem of dealing
with natural objects with shadows with
cracks with more than trying he drooled
vertexes in space and what to do about
that well that was a problem that
another graduate student David Waltz
said about to solve so waltz decided
that he would not be content unless he
added cracks shadows non trihedral
vertexes oh yeah non Fridays over Texas
and shadows over Texas and light these
considerations led walls to go from four
labels to 50-plus because he had to pack
a lot of information into each of the
labels that he put on the line what kind
of light was on the right what kind of
light was on the left maybe it's a crack
maybe it's a crack that all sorts of
considerations here we had 18 ways that
lines can come together around junctions
that went to thousands of junctions in
waltzes world
so here's Guzman he writes a program
that sort of works down below we have
Huffman
Huffman who has a theory but solves the
wrong problem so here's here comes walls
and he's trying to solve the right
problem with with a satisfying theory
that has a generalizable principle so
when we get all through with this we'll
talk about criteria for success and
we'll conclude that have a really
successful thing you need a problem to
start with you need a method that works
and you have to show that it works
because of some principle so guzman had
the problem and something that worked
Huffman had a method which worked on the
wrong problem and it's left to waltz to
bring it all together so waltz does all
of this work and now he has instead of
18 labels he has thousands instead of
four line labels he has more than 50 so
naturally it becomes difficult to work
these by hand we will able to work those
examples with and with those those
Huffman examples by hand we started with
labeling everything on the boundary and
worked our way and there's no particular
method there which is easy to work out
the puzzle but for waltz he didn't have
that luxury so he might have in a
typical scene you might have tens or
even hundreds of junctions to label and
no easy way of dealing with it
so naturally writes himself a
depth-first search program so here is
vertex or rather Junction number one
there are many choices for which label
can be used on it and for each of those
chain choices
whatever he's decided Junction number
two is has its own suite of
possibilities and so it becomes a simple
depth-first search problem right so in
actuality as soon as so as soon as waltz
he was my officemate at the time I could
tell you this for a fact as soon as he
wrote this program he kept looking over
at the computer they were big in those
days they all had lights so you looked
over the computer see if the lights were
still blinking
because he'd start this depth-first
search program up and nothing would
happen
he thought the computer had crashed
nothing happened
why did nothing happen because the
search space is exponential and much too
big for an ordinary computer or maybe
even an ordinary universe so walls has
to do something else he has to come up
with a new method for using all these
labels that he's that he's after about a
year and a half's worth of hard work
with lots of paper on his desk of little
blocks after a year and a half hard work
getting all these jokes and labels
figured out he didn't has to come up
with a method for figuring out how to
use them and so we don't know whether to
think his biggest contribution was that
label set or his method and probably
both deserve about equal billing oh I
don't know how did how to explain what
Waltz did well one way is to do an
example and I think I will hazard an
example let's see let me find some space
I think I'm reduced to going over here
but that'll be convenient since the line
levels are here
here's my example okay so how can I give
you just partial a part of a picture
well I can suit you can assume I'm
looking at this through a window so the
edge of the window form boundary lines
and they exert no constraint whatsoever
on what's behind them so this is a
legitimate drawing to have to think
about by the way is this ambiguous or do
you get a firm sense that there's an au
Niek interpretation of all those lines
I think it's there's a unique
interpretation of all those lines what
what I'm going to do is I'm actually
going to solve this problem using
Huffman's labels but waltzes method
because I can't simulate on a blackboard
something with with with 50 line types
and thousands of line junctions so I'm
going to use Huffman set to demonstrate
walsh's algorithm so Wilson's algorithm
involves starting out by plopping on
some Junction all of the possible things
that can all of the possible labels that
the the answer has to be drawn from so
let me number these in the order that
we're going to visit them so and so far
I've just put down the three fork
options that are resident on that first
Junction and I have to take note of
exactly what they do with the lines that
come out of the junction so let's say
I'll just copy them down one possibility
is this one another possibility is this
one and another possibility is + + -
oops I've got plus plus no that's right
so that right so far all I've done is
copy the the junction labelings from my
library and at this point Walters
algorithm says there's nothing else to
do but go onto Junction number
you and unfortunately sadly there are
lots of labelings that have to be
considered on junction number two six of
them one two three four five six so one
of them looks like that
another one looks like that one of them
is plus here arrow in another one is
plus here arrow out another one is minus
here arrow down and minus here arrow up
I think I've copied those alright but
now having copied those down Walt's
falses algorithm looks around at the
neighboring junctions and says are any
of the things that I just placed on
Junction 2 disallowed but what I've
already placed on a neighboring Junction
so it looks over here in step number two
and it sees that these three arrows
require the line that joins junctions 1
& 2 to be either minus or plus right so
of the six possibilities I can only keep
the ones that are likewise content to
put a plus on that line that joins the
two so that means that the influence
flowing from Junction 1 eliminates that
one eliminates that one eliminates that
one and eliminates that one so half of
them are gone
all the ones that try to put a boundary
line on that line between 1 & 2 or
disallow all right now likewise we could
say well of the remaining ones do they
restrict what I can do at Junction 1 so
let's see here's a minus and here's a
plus
so both of those both all of these
possibilities over here are still alive
so now continuing on we have to see what
we can do in junction 3 these are arrow
labels again so we have to copy exactly
the same label set as we had before and
now we look down on you look down in
junction to and say well what does that
tell me about the three that I've just
placed if we look up from Junction 2 to
see what kind of constraints it puts on
here we have this one alive and this one
a lot I guess we've eliminated four of
the six so we have these two alive and
they both put boundary lines I think I
must have had this boundary line wrong
right no that's right
oh yes I see huh Plus this little goes
hang on a second you've let me do
something wrong so plus it's out I know
it's the one that goes up this minus
goes up oh yes I'm I'm too hasty and
uncertain about what I was doing so
let's see this guy has a boundary going
down and this guy has a boundary going
up oh the others have been eliminated so
that means it's something that tries to
put a concave line there is gone and
something that tries to put a plus line
there is gone so the influence flowing
up in this direction in the third step
eliminates that guy and eliminates that
guy leaving only this guy but now the
thing I was worried about is you have to
also at this point go down to two and
see if there's any further constraint on
what can be what can survive down there
based on what has happened over here at
Junction 3 now let's see this one goes
up which is compatible with the survivor
but this one goes down which is not
compatible
with a survivor so when I bring this
down in step 3
this guy is eliminated so now I'm down
to just one interpretation for what can
be going on at vertex number two and one
interpretation for vertex number three
now let's see this can propagate so now
that I've made a change on vertex number
two I have to also see if that causes a
change in vertex number one so it's
propagating through and now I can see
that the only possibility here is a -
the label that's coming down from our
survivor so that eliminates these two
whew it's hard to do this by hand but
I've got three of the four things
labeled and even with just three of the
four labeled I'm down to a single
interpretation for all of the junctions
and the lines between them so there's
one left we have to deal with that fork
where tax will better deal with it
because for all we know this is not
illegal not illegal drawing in this
world we have five fork vertex is to
place but you know what I don't have to
draw much here because I know that this
is forced to be a plus now and this is
forced to be a plus now and there's only
one fork vertex with any pluses on it at
all so now I can come through and say
well the only possible survivor is this
one these are gone and now I have a
deter potations
for all of the junctions and I see that
the winners are this one and this one
and this one and this one so I've got a
unique interpretation this line is
convex
this one is concave this is a boundary
that's a boundary and this line is
convex and that's convex now that's a
lot of work so I better check and make
sure I got it right you'd like to see
this demonstrated to make sure I haven't
made a mistake
sure that right let's see add it so each
of the places where a line is obscured
has four possibilities labeled e the
arrow junctions are labeled a the forks
there are five of them at the fork
Junction five so let's just step through
here and see what happens boom I got it
I did do it right so let's try some more
what do you think will happen with this
one unique solution it stopped
bug in my program unthinkable what's
happened it is genuinely ambiguous it
can be something hanging down from the
ceiling or it could be something that we
can think of as a step going up from
left to right let's look at something
more complicated you think it'll work
not enough constraint for us to figure
that one out it's equally ambiguous but
a little bit larger example what about
this one you have it the stuff is
creeping up from the lower left up to
the upper right yeah bingo it worked
it's unambiguous its variation on the
same theme we had before but let me just
for fun take these two lines out what do
you think will happen now
seems to be doing just fine until it
hits the upper right-hand corner and
discovers it can't label stuff so it
propagates back down and what looked
okay and the lower left is no good after
all so these results are kind of
consistent with what we humans do when
we look at these kinds of things so it's
very likely that we in our heads do have
some constraint propagation apparatus
that we use in vision but putting that
aside and we can think about other kinds
of intelligence different from human
that might use this kind of mechanism to
solve problems and involve a lot of
constraint and finding a solution so
here we saw the constraint propagation
activity at work on line drawing
analysis but next time what we're going
to do is we're going to see it at work
on map coloring and who cares about map
coloring people who do scheduling
because that turns out to be the same
problem
you